Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm gonna do a
full recap of Dark season 2. Part of what
I love about this show is its complexity,
but I tried to keep this video on the
shorter side. That meant that I had to
leave out some of the smaller details
which I love. So make sure to drop a
comment if you have questions about
something that I didn't get into in this
recap. I plan on doing more dark videos
while we wait for season 3 so hit the
subscribe button if you're a fan of the
show. Obviously this is a recap of
everything that happened in Dark season
2 and will be full of spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet.
The first episode of Dark's second season
opens in a time period we haven't seen
yet. There are two characters, who at
first glance, aren't anyone we've seen
before. The time period is 1921 and the
characters who we see digging the
passage in the caves are a younger Noah
and who I presume to be an older Bartosz.
We never get confirmation that this is
Bartosz on screen but I would be shocked
to learn that's not the case.
Noah kills the second man with the
pickaxe after he accuses him of losing
his faith in their group Sic Mundus.
Before he struck down he tells Noah that
he hopes that a day will come where he
doesn't believe everything that Adam
tells him. He says that he should ask him
why he took him in and why he chose to
call him Noah. Adam, whose face is covered
with scar tissue, is the leader of
Sic Mundus, and the older Noah who we met
in season 1 is also a member. We learned
that they're looking for missing pages
from the triquetra notebook and Adam
says the apocalypse must come to pass.
Younger Jonas wakes up from a dream of
having sex with Martha in the future.
Remember he was sent there after
touching young Helge through the
wormhole that opened in the bunker in
the season 1 finale. Season 2 takes place
in June, episode 1 is on the 21st, so it's
just over six months removed from most
of the events from season 1 which
happened in November. Jonas has been
stuck in 2053 for a while and he wants
to travel back to stop the apocalypse on
June 27th. We see him collecting
materials and listening to tapes that
Claudia made at some time before he
arrived. Older Elisabeth Doppler is
in an important role in the future, she
guards the area around the nuclear plant
called the "dead zone",
and kills people who try to get inside.
At this point we don't know why she's
doing that other than we hear them say
Sick Mundus Creatus Est during a
hanging, but we do learn that Jonas is
determined to enter the power plant and
when he does he finds a mysterious
floating blob inside. In 2020 we meet a
new investigator named Clausen who we
later learn volunteered for the position
of starting a task force with Charlotte.
Six people have been missing for more
than six months in Winden and everyone
is on edge. Stranger Jonas arrives at his
childhood home right in time to
interrupt Hannah who's holding Boris
Niewald's gun to her throat. He reveals
his identity to his mother and also
tells her about her husband Michael's
true identity as Mikkel Nielsen. Some
other set up things that happen in the
premiere - Alexander Tiedemann announces
that the power plant will be closing
which means he has to hide the yellow
barrels. He decides to bury them under
concrete inside the plant so that no one
will be able to find them.
Bartosz and Martha break up and later
we see him meet Noah and go inside the
caves. In 1921 we see older Noah talking
to his younger self who's having a hard
time after killing the man at the caves.
Young Elizabeth finds a picture of Sic
Mundus in a book at HG Tannhaus' shop
and identifies Noah to Peter.
He tells Charlotte and we see that
they're working together putting
together clues in the bunker. In the
second episode old Claudia visits her
younger self to tell her about time
travel in Winden and later gives her a
map telling her where to find the time
machine. She stresses that her younger
self needs to stop Adam and plants the
seeds that things could turn out
differently with Regina and her father
if she succeeds. Egon Tiedemann is now
retired and has been diagnosed with
cancer. He begins thinking about things
and interviews Helge Doppler who resides
in a mental facility. He can't provide
any useful information about Mads'
disappearance the year before. Egon then
decides to inquire about the man he
arrested 34 years ago for the murders of
Eric and Yasin and the disappearance of
young Helge Doppler. It turns out Ulrich
is still alive and has been confined to
a psychiatric unit this whole time. He
doesn't tell Egon anything useful but
the interaction makes him suspect that
he was wrong
about what happened back in 1953. In
2020 Clausen and Charlotte visit Regina
Tiedemann for an interview
Clausen seems to have an interest in
Regina's husband Alexander. Regina
mentions that stranger Jonas stayed in
her hotel during the disappearances and
she gives them a box filled with his
belongings that he left behind.
Charlotte notices pages from her
grandfather's book and she makes an
excuse to leave. Elsewhere stranger Jonas
brings Hannah back to 1987 to show her
Mikkel living with a Ines. Hannah now
understands that her husband Michael was
a time traveler and the son of the man
she was having an affair with. In 2053
Jonas gets caught by Elizabeth trying to
re-enter the dead zone after gathering
fuel he needed to make things work. He's
about to be hanged
but Elisabeth saves him at the last
minute choosing to imprison him instead.
Her translator Silja frees Jonas
because she wants to know why Elisabeth
let him live and what she's hiding.
Jonas and Silja go back to the black
blob inside the power plant which we
found out is known as the god particle
from one of Claudia's tapes. The episode
ends as Jonas enters the stabilized god
particle
leaving Silja and 2053 behind. In Episode
three young Helge becomes the first
successful traveler through a new and
improved chair. Noah sends him back to
1954 where he returns home to everyone's
surprise. young Egon tries to learn what
happened from the boy but he won't speak
to anyone until older Noah comes to
visit him later.
Older claudia meets with Agnes Nielsen
in the bunker in 1954. We learned that
Agnes and Noah are siblings and that
she's on the outs with Sic Mundus.
Claudia gives her a newspaper clipping
which will see her take to Noah later in
an effort to rejoin Sic Mundus. we
learned that it's a story about
Claudia's death.
Claudia goes to visit her father at the
police station and then visits HG Tannhaus
for one last time. She gets
confronted by Noah who tells her she's
going to die. Before he shoots her
Claudia makes a comment about him being
a pawn in a game he still doesn't know
how to play. she says if you were free
you would have a choice and then he
kills her anyway. When Noah recovers the
missing pages from the notebook he's
visibly shook.
We hear him mention Charlotte's
name saying, "no, this isn't right. this
isn't true." in 1987 a lot of stuff
happens.
Ulrich tells Egon who he is and that
he's from the future. when he goes back
to visit him later he brings a photo of
Mikkel with him and that sets
Ulrich into a violent rage. Egon also
tells his daughter about his cancer.
Middle Claudia visits Tannhaus for the
first time with his book. He explains the
bootstrap paradox when something exists
because it was sent back in time and
therefore has no point of creation. He
tells her the book found me before I
even wrote it.
She then travels for the first time to
2020 where she looks in on Regina and
sees that she's sick.
In 1921 Adam asked Noah if he recovered
the pages from the triquetra notebook. he
says that Claudia got what she deserved
in the end we all get what we deserve. in
episode 4 we find out where Jonas went
after he entered the god particle. he's
in 1921 where he meets a young or Noah
who later takes him to meet Adam in his
lair under the church. Adam reveals that
he is the oldest version of Jonas and I
for one believe that. in 2020 adult
Claudia is at the library doing research
on what happened to her and her father.
she learns that her father died and that
she disappeared. she then goes back to
1987. in 2020 with three days to go until
the apocalypse things are starting to
take shape. Martha, Franziska, Elisabeth and
Magnus start working together to figure
out what's going on and eventually they
run into Bartosz in the caves. they end up
taking the time machine from him not
knowing what it is and they leave him
there overnight. Hannah and Stranger
Jonas talk to Charlotte and after
sharing what they know decide to tell
Katharina about it. at first she thinks
they're all crazy but later goes to the
school and finds Mikkel in the 1986
class photo. Clausen also interviews
Aleksander learning that his last name
was Koehler before he married Regina, but
we don't know why this is important yet.
in the fifth episode Adam tells Jonas
that he can change the future and the
past if he prevents his father from
killing himself. Adam shows Jonas his god
particle time machine under the church
which can operate outside the 33 year cycle
and take you to any day you want to
travel to.
Jonas travels to the day before Michael
committed suicide in. 1987 Ulrich breaks
out of the psychiatric ward and finds
Mikkel but they get caught by the police
before they can enter the caves.
Claudia also learns about the yellow
barrels from Bernd Doppler who asked her
to keep things a secret at least until
he dies. in 2020 Charlotte reveals to
stranger Jonas that Tannhaus is not
her real grandfather and that she never
knew her parents. later Noah finds
Charlotte and reveals that he is her
father but won't reveal who her mother
is. the teens make Bartosz show them how
the time machine works and they take a
brief trip to the 1980s. when they return
Martha finds the St. Christopher pendant
that stranger Jonas left on her pillow.
episode 6 is the odd episode in this
season that doesn't occur in the lead-up
to the apocalypse. instead we are in 2019
the day before Michael kills himself.
young Jonas arrives from 1921 which
means we have two versions of the
younger Jonas walking around at the lake.
the original one finds the st.
Christopher pendant while he's sitting
with Martha. they talk and almost kiss but
he leaves abruptly telling her that he
has to go teach his grandma how to use
her new tablet. traveling young Jonas
then pulls a switcheroo because in his
mind he's going to talk his father out
of committing suicide which will mean
he'll never exist.
he tells Martha you and I are perfect for
each other never believe anything else.
they share a kiss which will lead to his
slightly younger self getting laid later
that evening. the Nielsen's are throwing
a party to celebrate Katharina and
Ulrich's wedding anniversary. young Jonas
and Hannah go to the party while the
traveling young Jonas talks to his
father.
we learn that Michael hasn't been
suicidal and he reveals that it was
Jonas who led him into the caves and
took him to 1986. older Claudia arrives
and tells the Jonas that Michael must
kill himself so everything happens the
same way it always has. Jonas is
persuaded and after a tearful goodbye he
leaves Michael to write his suicide
letter. in episode 7 older Claudia's dead
body
is discovered in the woods in 1954. Egon
thinks that she may have played a part
in Helge's kidnapping.
he asked the boy about her but he only
responds by calling Claudia the white
devil. after stealing the time machine
from stranger Jonas Hannah arrives in
this time period to visit Ulrich after
talking to him she decides to leave him
where he is.
later in Egons office she says that
she's looking for a fresh start
indicating that she might stay in 1954
for a while.
in 1987 it's the day of her father's
death and Claudia is trying to prevent
it. he tells her that he knows about time
travel and she tries to play dumb at
first. things escalate to where he
figures out that she knows and she gets
angry. he tries to call the police to
tell them what he knows and they get
into a fight where she tries to take the
phone from him. he falls busting his head
open on a table and she decides to let
him bleed out thinking that this has to
happen so that he will later be saved.
before he dies he says you are the white
devil when she returns to her home
younger traveling Jonas arrives and
tells her that they have to leave. he
says he knows what she did but says it
doesn't have to happen that way again.
when she asked where they're going he
says the future.
Clausen confronts Aleksander at the power
plant revealing that he had a brother
named Aleksander Koehler who went missing
in 1986, and that he is not him. in the
season 2 finale
Jonas explains to Claudia everything
that her older self knew about time
travel and the coming apocalypse. Jonas
suggests that they probably can't change
the big things using time travel but
perhaps they can change the details. he
says we can change a grain of sand, and
with that the whole world.
Charlotte learns that Alexander buried
the radioactive waste and she's worried
that Clausen investigation will lead
him to it. she heads over to the power
plant to try to stop him. we learned that
after finding out that Charlotte was his
daughter
Noah decided that he had to kill Adam
and he sets out to do that. Adam isn't
fazed by this saying it's not his
destiny to die yet. Noah tries but is
unable to shoot him and in the process
it's revealed that Noah's wife is an
older Elisabeth
meaning Elisabeth is both
Charlotte's daughter and her mother. as
Adam is telling him that, "this knot can
only be undone by destroying it
completely," Agnes and older Magnus and
who we presume is the older Franziska
enter the room.
Agnes takes the gun from Noah and she's
able to use it to kill him. adult Jonas
finds Martha and forces her to go into
the bunker at gunpoint. he says he can't
watch her die again and begs her to stay
there. you might be thinking that this
doesn't make sense because his younger
self saw her die and for me this is one
of those things that make Dark great. even
though he knows it probably won't work
he still feels compelled to try, which is
what I imagine all of us would do in
that situation even knowing full well
that we were at the mercy of a
deterministic universe. at the nuclear
plant Clausen gains access and pretty
much goes straight to where the yellow
barrels are buried. young Jonas and
Claudia go through the caves and
activate the time machine opening the
portal back up. he explains that he's
accepted that he needs to play a part in
the disaster that he wants to prevent.
Peter takes Elisabeth to the bunker to
keep her safe, and when they open the
door Martha runs out to find Jonas
Claudia finds Regina and also brings her
to the bunker. young Jonas and Martha are
reunited at his home where Adam shows up.
Adam travelled to 2020 through the god
particle and he's there to kill Martha.
he shoots her and explains that in order
for him to exist
Jonas had to see her die and feel that
pain. in 2053 we see Elisabeth go inside
the dead zone and activate the god
particle at the same time that Claussen
is having one of his police force use a
jackhammer to break into the concrete
that was poured over the yellow barrels.
Charlotte gets there and tries to stop
him but he won't listen to her. he
insists on opening it. at that same time
elisabeth activates the god particle in
2053. older Magnus and his partner
activate theirs in 1921 and we watch as
the contents inside the yellow barrel
that Claussen opened becomes the god
particle. we watch as a portal opens
we're Elisabeth in 2053 can see
Charlotte in 2020 they go to touch each
other and that's when the apocalypse
hits Winden. we know that several of the
characters died because we saw their
graves in 2053 when Jonas was there. he's
still in his home at Martha's side and
before the explosion can reach it he's
saved by a version of Martha who tells
him that she's from a different world
and that is where the season ends. so the
original Martha dies and we learn that
there is one from a different world,
however you want to describe it, who
swoops in and she takes Jonas somewhere.
we have to imagine it's wherever she
came from.
Claudia, Regina, Charlotte, and Peter, and
also young Noah who showed up there,
survived in the bunker. stranger Jonas
found
Franziska, Magnus, and Bartosz and took
them somewhere before the explosion hit.
it certainly makes sense that they'll
end up in the 1921 timeline but we don't
know how many stops or what's going to
happen between now and then. we don't
know what happened to the older
Elizabeth in Charlotte when they touched
where they ended up so it's pretty
exciting heading into season 3. let me
know if you have any questions in the
comments because I'm gonna leave it
there. please like this video if you
enjoyed it and subscribe to my channel
if you haven't already and you're a fan
of Dark I have more Dark videos coming
up and thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon.